-Now, I did not know this.
Beanie, a name given to you
by your nanny.
Is that correct?
-Yes.
-How´d it come about?
-I had a nanny when I young.
My mom was working.
And my given name is Elizabeth.
And she called me Elizabeanie,
´cause that´s a popular
British nickname.
-Oh, okay.
-And my brothers are much older.
They´re like,
"Let´s just call her Beanie.
That´s so funny."
And it totally stuck.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-So you had no decision in this
at all?
-No, but everyone was like,
"At 10,
you´ll want to be Elizabeth.
At 16" --
Everyone had a different age.
They were like,
"You´re gonna outgrow it."
And I was like, "No."
I love it.
-Oh, good.
Well, that works out good.
So, your brother is Jonah Hill?
-Yes.
-And he has been here before
and talked about your mother
being a very funny character.
-Yes.
-A wonderful mother as well.
But you stayed with her
recently.
She made you stay with her while
you were shooting this film.
-Yes.
Sharon, Shea, as we call her.
She´s the best.
-The nanny --
Did the nanny give her Shea?
-No, I did.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
She´s truly the best woman
on planet Earth.
But she´s a character.
And I was basically told
the day I stay in a hotel
over staying with her would be
like the worst day of her life.
-Okay, gotcha.
-So when we were filming
"Lady Bird,"
I was staying with my parents.
And I came home one day
and she was geschreing,
which is Yiddish for, like,
screaming her face off.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Turning purple, like --
And I hear it, and I´m, like,
running into her office,
and she´s, like,
screaming on the phone.
She´s like,
"I am my dog´s advocate!
Okay?"
She´s --
I´m like, "What´s going on?"
I realize
she´s talking to the vet.
[ Laughter ]
And she´s like --
She´s like,
"My dog can´t speak English!
My dog can´t tell you when
he´s upset, so I speak for him."
She´s screaming.
[ Laughter ]
And I´m like,
"What is going on?"
She hangs up.
I´m like, "What´s going on?"
She´s like,
"I´m mad at the vet."
And just, like, walks out of
the room. I´m like, "What?"
The next day, my parents get
a registered letter,
which is like one step
under getting served, right?
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Like, it´s basically
getting served.
-In this day,
if it´s too much for an e-mail,
that´s a huge deal.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
You have to sign for it, okay?
So they get a registered letter
to our house
that says in not so many words
that my parents are never
welcome at the vet ever again.
-And we have the letter --
and this is my favorite thing,
´cause it´s so clearly
from the vet,
´cause at the end it says,
"If your next veterinarian has
any questions
regarding Brewski´s care."
[ Laughter ]
"Please" --
-"You have made it impossible
for the doctors and staff here
to communicate with you."
-That´s the best.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, also, like,
I have to assume
the vet doesn´t know
how to do that.
I feel like they talk
and they´re like,
"What should we do?"
And they´re like,
"I think there´s a thing, like,
in the legal profession
where you send
a registered letter?"
-Exactly. "I think that
we´re able to do that."
-Yeah. Oh, my God.
That´s really, really great.
So this -- tell us about
the part you play.
Because you are -- you´re
a student in a Catholic school.
As we can tell from the clip.
-Yes. Yes.
-Did you have any background
in that?
-Certainly not.
Feldstein -- quite Jewish.
-Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, geschreing didn´t
seem like something
that you heard a lot
in Catholic schools.
-Exactly. And it was amazing,
because I learned so much.
Saoirse, she´s not American,
but she is Catholic.
Or she was raised Catholic.
And so she was teaching me
the Hail Mary
and I was teaching her
the pledge of allegiance.
-Oh, perfect.
-Because we had, like,
all of these classroom scenes
where we had to do
both of those things.
And I was like, "Okay,
´I pledge allegiance.´"
She was like, "Hail Mary,
full of grace."
I was like, "Okay, okay."
Sort of feeding each other lines
back and forth. Yeah.
-And what drew you to the part
you play in this?
-I love this movie so much.
Greta Gerwig is a genius.
-She´s wonderful.
-And she wrote
the most amazing script.
And it said --
when I got the script,
it said Julie, 17, chubby,
gets the lead
in her high school musical.
And I was like, "Excuse me?"
[ Laughter ]
"Sounds great."
It just felt like
such a perfect fit.
And the story of a young girl.
We just don´t have
enough of these
complicated female roles
and female movies
and specifically Julie
just, like,
felt like a very good fit
for me.
-So you´re on Broadway
right now.
You´re doing "Hello, Dolly!"
with Bette Midler.
You also --
You went to theater camp.
You knew you wanted to do this
for a long time.
-Yes.
-What´s it called, Stagedoor?
-Stagedoor Manor.
And you -- Is that where
you meet Ben Platt?
-That´s not where
I met Ben Platt.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Ben and I have been
best friends --
We met at a bat mitzvah,
actually.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Of course.
-A Catholic bat mitzvah?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, of course.
I was wearing my uniform
that I wear in the film.
-Okay, gotcha.
It would be really funny
to do a Catholic-themed
bat mitzvah.
[ Laughter ]
-I´m in. I´m so in.
No, of course,
Ben and I both had, like,
theater-themed bar mitzvah
and bat mitzvahs.
-Gotcha.
-But we met at a bat mitzvah,
and this was before cellphones.
So we didn´t have any way
to, like, stay in touch.
He joined my school in 9th grade
and we instantly became
best friends.
And sort of the way that, like,
he knew we were best friends
was like the second
week of school.
He got his braces off
and he texted me, like,
"I got my braces off."
And I left my class
to come see his teeth.
[ Laughter ]
And I´m such a goodie-goodie
and I love school.
So he was like,
"I must mean a lot to you
because you left
to see my teeth."
-What did the teacher say
when you just got up and left?
-I mean, I think I was like,
"I have to pee," or something.
[ Laughter ]
I played it off, Seth.
Obviously I played it off.
-Okay, gotcha.
Good, because you´re so
successfully now,
I can´t believe you just would
have burned down high school
to see a pair of teeth.
Well, thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the film.
-Oh, my gosh, I´m so honored.
Truly.
-Such a pleasure
to have you here.